tonight we're remembering the sacrifices
made by americans on 9 11. sandy
bradshaw was a flight attendant on
united flight 93 the hijacked plane that
went down in pennsylvania to remember
her her mother attends the memorial in
her hometown every year melissa painter
from our sister station brings us the
story of what it means that the
community continues to honor her
daughter's legacy
my mother called me and
said do you have your tv on and i said
no and she said well turn it on some
plane crashed into a building in new
york most of us of a certain age have
strong memories of september 11 2001.
most of us though don't have a daughter
who died on one of the hijacked planes
i'm sure that she was that she did her
part because that was the person she was
pat wah is the mother of sandy bradshaw
bradshaw was a flight attendant on
united airlines flight 93
bradshaw and others on board thwarted
the terrorist plans instead the plane
crashed into a field in shanksville
pennsylvania killing all on board 20
years later wa's home is decorated with
mementos that remind her of her daughter
and what happened that day that's always
helped me
to talk about it but
i struggled for a long time
and she still struggles but keeping the
legacy of her brave daughter alive helps
most years she attends a 9 11 ceremony
at eastern randolph high school where
her daughter graduated in 1981. that
annual ceremony also recognizes first
responders who serve our community wall
says it's a reminder to the generation
not even born in 2001 that the
sacrifices of that day continue on i
hope that people will remember
9 11 not i mean not just because of
sandy but because of what it was and
you know our our world changed that day
not just ours personally but
our whole world changed and it's never
been the same since we must never forget
that was melissa painer reporting